now last week after Florida confirmed
the state flew migrants to California
which is a sanctuary State Oh California
governor Gavin Newsom he posted this
tweet threatening Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis with kidnapping charges they
did sign waivers now this despite the
fact that the Biden Administration
they've been flying illegal immigrants
all over the country often Landing in
the dead of night wonder why also
repeated assertions from Florida
officials that illegal immigrants all
willingly made that trip we did ask
Governor Newsom about his Feud with
Governor DeSantis and whether he would
agree to a debate one-on-one with me
hosting here's what he had to say
here's my question maybe I have an idea
that you'd agree with I want to start a
series of debates and get some of the
best brightest leading conservative
minds and some of the best brightest
left-wing minds or liberal Minds that I
put you in that category and I want to
call it like the great debates love it
and the first one I want to do is with
you and Governor DeSantis great I've
offered it I've been trying to debate
here's how this debate format will go
good I'll say Governor Newsom Governor
DeSantis
economy that's the only word I'm going
to throw out of it you minute minute
then you go at it next topic right and
I'll moderate it that way and you have
my word I'll moderate it that way I I'm
all in count on you you would do a
two-hour debate with Rhonda said I make
it three three hour debate yeah
with one day notice with no notes I look
forward to that we can talk about his
zest for demonization we could talk
about his assault on him a kidnapper uh
everything I said question mark still
being interested the question mark was
the real investigated and you may bring
charges the people you know kind of you
you're what kind of Faith tradition how
nice was it three people like this so
Ron descendants to the goodness of his
heart he's going around the country to
try to help migrants and bring them to
States
why is it that he sends a plane load of
people to Martha's Vineyard a liberal
Enclave right from one and a half
million bucks okay what happens who's
the fiscal conservative part we went and
we looked there were more than double
the amount of rooms available for every
one of the people that that landed there
that day okay and all of them signed a
waiver all of them by the way come on
they said I read the waiver they showed
me the way I couldn't even understand it
and I have body decent education they
got the the sanctuary liberal Enclave
couldn't handle you know 50 illegal
immigrants
24 hours they were children then why did
they why do they do that why did Martha
why do you use people as pawns I mean
they said What Faith tradition teaches
you to treat human beings like this to
belittle that you to be an awful
Sanctuary State you should why don't you
Embrace about dealing with the cards
that are dealt and for comprehensive
immigration reform I'm proud of our
president for putting a strategy out and
you guys have been silenced on it you
haven't even discussed it yet a
sanctuary State why don't you embrace
them and say thank you for sending them
I wasn't we brace everybody here we deal
with the cards of date in a human way
foreign
thing I don't think this happened I know
it I sat down with these migrants I
talked to every single one of them they
were lied to they were misled
they were told they had jobs they told
they were going to get certain court
dates changed they were dropped off they
knocked on the door and they left and it
was not coordinated I mean what kind of
Faith tradition everything else there's
a video humanization of the people
getting on the because they were all
lied to and told and they were being
taken care of everything's going to be
great I would be loud and happy then
then because by the way I have the RFP
because they landed in your Sanctuary
State you're going to take care of them
they should be happy look we'll we'll
deal with the car come on this is
California I know it's called okay
on this way the fourth largest economy
in the world we can handle of course we
have this okay I'm a border state Rhonda
Santos is not I know he's desperate to
get into the ACT no because a lot of
belly flops Donald Trump is going to
clean the Joe Biden DeSantis belly
flopped do you will clean his clock I
don't have a crystal attention and he
set this up months ago by doing an RFP I
have the contractor okay my question he
tried to hire saying he was going to
send people to California this is a
stunt it's embarrassing not pathetic I I
just did not I think he did the right
thing his State's not a sanctions well
Joe Biden just wanted to help people you
will you apply the same standard to Joe
Biden he's flying all these illegal
immigrants coordinating them
coordinating excuse me I'm engaged
directly with the administration at 3 30
in the morning in Westchester Airport
not LaGuardia not Kennedy Westchester
you know why because they're sneaking
him in when States aren't looking and
Counting perfect but they're
coordinating there's a different Spirit
there's a different level of Engagement
level it's different in daylight and
darkness it's not perfect there's some
humility in this well isn't Joe Biden
dumping people in Florida all these
other states isn't dumb people anywhere
what's the
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else